the actual story of the press conference
is that joe biden is not with us
he was repeatedly confused he wandered
off in the middle of sentences
he never came back he did it at least
three separate times during the press
conference
here's a little bit of joe biden just
wandering off into the into the
cornfield and we have no idea where old
joe went
am i giving you too long an answer
because if you don't want the detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there infinity so the
best way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're we're going to get a lot done
but folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
okay that second that second statement
there
is just that is not somebody who's with
us
we can pretend we can we can all pretend
everything is fine
i'll just note that for four long years
every single thing that donald trump
said or did was used as an excuse
by the left and by the media as a as a
hook
to suggest that the 25th amendment
should be invoked
because he was not competent to fulfill
high office joe biden
wanders off in the middle of sentences
he doesn't know where he is or what he
is doing
and the media proclaimed him to be an
incredible president an incredible order
five minutes into this press conference
there were reporters who were tweeting
out about how contr how in control he
was by the end of the press conference
he had to be mopped off the floor and it
wasn't as though he was asked out
questions because he really was not
more joe biden seeming confused falling
apart
and that one clip of him falling apart
is just the this is this is the one here
here is joe biden again any president
who did this
who was not a democrat would immediately
immediately
be expected to resign in in fairly near
order i mean if you watch this press
conference and the first question that
flashed your brain was not how long can
this guy last i'm not sure what you were
watching here was joe biden yesterday
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done
what what remember
he's completely in command he's in
control the drudge report which is
basically turned hard left now the
drudge report's headlines today are
joe's no drama press conference chill
style
grand vision for fdr presidency art of
the possible
those are the headlines over at drudge
report which as you'll recall used to be
a critic
of presidents who are of the left side
of the aisle now the drudge report is
apparently joining the stenography club
over at the over at the democratic
press establishment outlets by the way
joe biden couldn't get through this
press conference without notes okay he
was he was reading
from actual podium notes throughout the
press conference
he had a binder he was reading from a
briefing book
at the press conference because he
cannot be trusted to go out there and
simply riff
on topics not because like president
trump he makes wild statements or wild
generalizations but because
he literally is unable to speak with
coherence on a topic
for more than five minutes it's an
amazing thing amazing thing
here was chris wallace pointing this out
hey chris wallace again no opponent of
joe biden's chris wallace has been
fairly warm toward joe biden here's
chris wallace from fox news
it seemed on every foreign policy
question not the others but on foreign
policy
he went to his briefing book like jenn
saki does
uh sometimes in the briefings and was
reading obviously white house
guidance white house talking points uh
covering ronald reagan for six years i
never saw that uh
watching a lot of news conferences over
the years i've never seen that
a president and a news conference
reading talking points
remember ronald reagan was a dullard
actor who was in decline according to
the press
and donald trump was apparently insane
person who was in decline according to
the press and joe biden who's clearly in
decline is completely with it
he's sharp as a thumbtack according to
the new york post however
a newspaper that is not in the pocket of
the democratic party president biden
appeared to repeatedly lose his train of
thought early on in his first press
conference as commander-in-chief
thursday
asking reporters if they wanted him to
go into detail in his answers for
getting questions relying heavily on cue
cards from a binder he brought along
the president took ten questions at the
62 minute presser repeatedly consulting
his binder before calling on the next
reporter by the way
when the washington post suggested he
took 29 questions they meant that he
took like
little follow-ups from the same
reporters but overall he filibustered a
bunch of these questions he'd be asked a
question if he didn't want to answer it
he would just
ramble for several minutes on completely
unrelated topics
the first awkward moment occurred when
the president was answering a question
on the crisis at the southern border
from pbs journalist yamiche alcindor who
by the way again another prestanographer
for the president of the united states
he he cut himself off in the middle of
the answer
he took alcindor's follow-up questions
in which she asked about the
deliberations for migrants being
permitted to stay as well as the
filibuster and then
he took her question on migrants and
needed to be reminded about her
filibuster query he just forgot the
second question
now listen we have a robust system we
have a robust system that is capable of
carrying on even if the president of the
united states does not seem to be with
us
but it is the gap between the reality
and how the media wish you to perceive
the reality that is
really worth talking about today i mean
biden was struggling to he had a list of
reporters he was going to call on
on that list was not fox news we'll get
to in a second imagine if president
trump
because he did this a couple of times
took press conferences and didn't once
call
on anyone from the left side of the
aisle he really didn't do that he called
on people from the left side of the
aisle just not cnn
and the press were like he's trying to
avoid questions joe biden would not call
on anyone from fox news
which is really the only opposition
outlet in the room okay but he did
have a pre-screened list of questioners
how transparent how refreshing and then
he got lost on his list he couldn't
remember who he was supposed to call on
here was joe biden yesterday okay
um hang on uh
sorry oh sing me
miss kim i mean this is incredible guys
he this is the leader of the free world
and also
a man who just starts yelling for no
reason he's talking about unions and all
of a sudden he's just like
turns in the swedish chef the hell is he
doing no one knows
so i'm running for three reasons to
restore the soul
dignity honor honesty transparency
to the american political system
two to rebuild the backbone of this
country
the middle class hard-working people
people struggling in the middle class
they built america
and unions built them what are you why
are you yelling
why did somebody did somebody lose the
the
discount coupon to the early bird dinner
at denny's again why
why are you angry no why are you yelling
okay then we'll get to his actual policy
because here's the thing
the combination of the trojan horse that
is biden i've suggested that he's a
house plant because he's hiding the
water stain
the water stain is the radical policy
when you bring out a person who is
clearly feeble
and then you put him out there and it's
impossible to make jokes about a person
like this
honestly like it's very difficult to
make jokes about joe biden
not because in the democratic view he's
just so wonderful but because in reality
making jokes about people like biden in
biden's particular
position it seems mean and it seems
cruel because the man is clearly not
with us
and then they use the fact that he's not
with us in order to ram through a bunch
of untruths a bunch of lies a bunch of
radical policy positions
that extra that in extraordinary fashion
reshape the relationship between the
american people and their government
we'll get to that and the media just
cheer it they just cheer because this is
what they want this is what they've
always wanted
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
here don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity
hit the like button